En ce moment, ma vie est compliquée.
Aelys me force à fabriquer de la drogue.
Enfin, disons plutôt que si je ne la fabrique pas, il me bute.
La journée, je fabrique de la froguine.
Mais...
Parallèlement à ça...
J'aide les villageois à se désintoxiquer.
Si Aelys découvre que j'aide les villageois...
Je suis mort.
Je dois cacher mon identité.
C'est pourquoi, grâce à la magie du théâtre...
Je deviens quelqu'un d'autre.
Avec ça !
Adieu, Yorel.
Bonjour Jean-Philippe.
Bon, je bosse encore la voix.
Belyr ?
Belyr, réveille-toi !
La résistance...
Tu bois trop de froguine Belyr, ça te rend malade. Allez, viens !
Y a un nouveau moine au village, il pourra peut-être t'aider. Allez, viens !
Non, non, les moines c'est des traitres.
Mais non, mais celui-là il est bien.
Il fait des cures de désintox et après on fait du théâtre d'improvisation. C'est super sympa.
Du théâtre ?
Oui.
Ici, je suis Jean-Philippe.
J'ai fabriqué un remède contre le manque.
Maintenant, je vais soigner le mental de ces pauvres gens par la paroles.
Bienvenue dans ce groupe de discussion.
Où nous allons partager, ensemble, nos souffrances.
C'est le chemin vers la guérison.
Un premier témoignage ?
Bonjour je m'appelle Jean-Michel.
Bonjour Jean-Michel.
Non, non, non, le principe c'est que tu restes...
Et que tu partages tes problèmes avec le groupe, ça va t'aider.
Ok. Alors, en fait, moi avant j'étais vendeur de catapultes.
C'est un secteur hyper compétitif.
Du coup pour améliorer mes performances, j'ai pris de la froguine.
Je pensais qu'à ça.
J'avais plus l'esprit clair. Un jour j'ai donné le bain à un rocher et j'ai mis mon fils dans la catapulte...
J'ai tiré, il est parti...
Il a crié "papa".
Oh...
Merci Jean-Michel.
Quand as-tu pris de la froguine pour la première fois ?
Jamais.
J'ai jamais pris ça moi.
Je pensais qu'on pouvait juste parler.
Oui, mais le principe c'est de parler de son parcours...
Pour arrêter la froguine.
C'est un groupe aux personnalités hétérogènes.
Certains sont plus en retard que d'autres.
Du coup, ça se passe comment ?
D'abord on raconte sa vie et ensuite vous nous donnez de la froguine, c'est ça ?
Ah non, non, non.
Ici, on est là pour arrêter la froguine.
Quoi ?
Y a ils sont bêtes, ils sont vraiment bêtes.
Vous savez dans la vie, faire un faux pas ça arrive à tout le monde.
Ça n'est pas de votre faute.
Exact.
Moi je pense que c'est surtout de la faute de la personne qui fabrique cette merde.
Alors oui, et non.
Peut-être que cette personne est en partie responsable.
Mais peut-être aussi qu'elle a subit des pressions de son côté.
Oh la pauvre personne, elle a été abandonné. Bah oui.
Tout seul, dans un château, comme ça, avec 3 repas chauds par jour et du chauffage.
Mais tu te fous de moi, Yorel, là ?
J'avais peur !
Je savais pas quoi faire !
Mais moi aussi, j'avais peur !
Je me suis retrouvé tout seul dans un donjon.
J'ai failli crever, t'en avais rien à foutre !
C'est pas vrai !
On s'est inquiété avec Clarisse !
Ouais, vous étiez inquiet, ouais.
Ouais !
Ouais.
Et tu t'es pas posé la question que peut-être tu me manquais aussi ?
Toi aussi tu me manques !
Non, toi tu me manques !
Toi tu me manques !
Non, toi !
Toi, tu me manques, ouais !
Toi !
Je te demande pardon !
Mais non, c'est moi qui te demande pardon.
Je t'adore, en plus.
Ok.
On va faire une petit pause.
Il me force à fabriquer de la drogue.
Je fais des journées de 20h, je suis épuisé.
Et puis il a vendu Clarisse.
Quoi ?
Putain, il est tellement malin.
Non, non, mais évidemment c'est horrible pour Clarisse.
Il est tellement malin.
Bon, faut que je rentre au château, faut que je retire ça sinon je vais me faire griller.
Tiens.
Prend ça.
Ça va t'aider.
Salut.
Je m'appelle Geneviève.
Daniel.
Je voulais juste te dire que j'ai trouvé ça très mignon ce que vous vous êtes dit avec le mestre du château.
Vraiment, c'était très mignon.
Comme tu sais qu'il est du château ?
Oh bah ça se voit, hein.
Toi aussi d'ailleurs, ça se voit.
C'est à cause du vocabulaire.
Les dents.
Et encore, j'en ai perdu 4, hein.
Oh le frimeur.
C'est vrai.
Non mais je me demandais, si ça te disais qu'on aille se...
Bah qu'on aille se balader...
Tous les deux...
Bah ouais, ouais, carrément.
Ouais ?
Ouais.
Cool.
Genre maintenant ?
Ouais.
Ouais ?
Ouais, ouais.
Bah c'est vrai, je me rend compte que j'étais un peu rentre dedans avec lui.
Mais, voilà, moi dans mon village l'espérance de vie est de 35 ans...
J'en ai 26, donc je profite de la vie, je fonce.
Attend, parce que désolé, j'ai pas l'habitude avec les villageoises.
Y a pas de mal.
Je te mets une patate dans les côtes ?
Non, non. On va pas faire ça. C'est pas cool ça.
Je te tire les cheveux ?
Enfin, ce qui serait cool, c'est qu'on est là, on est dans l'herbe, on se fait juste des petits bisous tu vois, tranquillement.
Ouais.
D'accord ?
Ok.
Allez.
Oh... Comme il est mignon ce petit couple.
Aelys.
Qu'est ce que tu fais là ?
J'ai des espions.
C'est marrant.
Je pensais que tu serais chez toi tranquille.
En train de compter ton or ou de broyer des gens.
Non mais j'ai tout fini ce matin, alors je me balade.
C'est qui ?
C'est un connard, fait pas attention.
Je suis le seigneur du Royaume des Frogz.
Dont la légendaire devise est "les dragons dragonnent".
Les mystères sont de mise.
C'était pas "d'un nénuphar à l'autre" ?
On a changé !
Ok.
Je suis donc le seigneur et la loi m'accorde certains privilèges.
Qu'est ce que tu fais ?
Je vais la droit de cuisser.
Non, t'as pas le droit de faire ça.
J'ai tellement le droit de faire ça.
Je vais la droit de cuisser.
Tu peux pas la droit de cuisser.
Comment je vais la droit de cuisser.
Arrête de la droit de cuisser.
Je la droit de cuisse et je la droit de cuisse.
Yorel ?
Ouais ?
Il peut la droit de cuisser ?
Il peut la droit de cuisser.
Faut pas qu'il la droit de cuisse.
Il va la droit de cuisser.
Je vais la droit de cuisser.
Arrête de la droit de cuisser.
Yorel, empêche-le de la droit de cuisser.
Je peux pas l'empêcher de la droit de cuisser.
Dans le donjon je la droit de cuisse.
Arrête !
Excusez-moi ?
Personne me demande à moi si j'ai envie d'être droit de cuisser ?
C'est la loi !
Ok.
Je vais la droit de cuisser, comme un petit fou.
Ça sonnait sexuel ?
C'est le cas !
Bon dimanche.
Fais quelque chose, putain.
Mais je peux rien faire.
Prends une potion...
- T'as pas une potion ?
Mais je peux rien faire.
Qu'est ce que tu veux que je fasse ?
Yorel ?
Déchire un truc !
Fais pas ça.
Fais pas ça. Yorel...
Fais pas ça !
Oui, alors effectivement, l'espion c'était moi.
Oui.
C'était moi parce qu'il se trouve que j'ai une grosse addiction à la froguine.
Et forcément, voilà, il faut financer.
Ça se fait beaucoup, hein, ce genre de chose.
Balancer les gens, comme ça, ça se fait beaucoup.
Et plus on est sympa, plus c'est discret.
Donc pour moi, c'était tout bon quoi.
Voilà. Donc effectivement, j'étais l'espion, à ce moment-là.